hi there that's the fear
how old is furture 101 although he's a
hundred and one voucher has never had
surgery he shows no signs of heart
disease and he takes no medication he
believes that his long life and his
incredible health is down to his diet so
any particular diet simple Punjabi
farmers died just fresh food very
secretive yes smaller portions in poor
countries people die starvation in rich
countries people die overeating so how
much does he eat say compared to you or
I he would eat half a portion so child
portions probably about half the amount
of calories your I would eat
welcome back to the D show and I'm with
not one but two special guests Michele
Gillespie and Jim Marlowe all right you
guys have been studying nutrition for
how long now and tell us a little about
yourselves
Michele I've been studying nutrition
since I joined the Peace Corps in 2004 I
at that time I was eating chili cheese
burritos and a bunch of junk and the
Peace Corps said you're gonna be a
nutritionist and I guess they made a
pretty good decision it that was one of
the things that got me interested in
nutrition and I've been learning more
ever since and yourself you no stranger
to the show forty years you were sick
and tired of being sick and tired it's
over forty years since then you took a
turn and started not quite 40 years yeah
but at the age of 20 I reached a point
in my life where I was sick and tired of
being sick and tired all the time and I
decided it was time for me to take
responsibility for my own health and
learn how to be healthy and nutrition
was a big part of that and I began to
develop my nutritional integrity very
important concept nutritional integrity
is all about setting standards for what
is acceptable food and drink for your
body and then being faithful to those
standards and nutritional integrity
always involves eating real food rather
than fake food that we talked about last
time I was now was that around the age
of what 21 days you're going on 40 years
you've been you've been studying this
going on 40 close to right well I'm 58
yeah yeah yeah tell it tell us now the
food that you're eating hmm can that be
food that is actually helping you to
live a more vibrant life or actually it
could be killing you of course
yes well the food that that Michelle
eats the food that I eat is helping us
to be as healthy as we can be so we can
live our life more fully and more richly
because how how fully and richly we can
we live our lives is very much dependent
on our energy our vitality and that's
that adds up to our level of health
the the better we nourish ourselves the
easier we make it for our body to be
healthier at the very least let's talk
about imma show some of the consequences
of not eating right not nourishing your
body with what the fuel that it really
needs that the the the the fuel that
helps you to live a more vibrant healthy
life the consequences of not doing that
yeah ordinances yeah well it affects
everything but I think the top three
that I like to think of our energy and
mood and mental clarity if you're not
eating very well energy affects
everything you do right we got energy
but what was the other one
energy mood and mental clarity at the
top three I mean that this is on me
right there you can see the majority of
people out there you know you feel that
sluggish feeling you know you're not
getting up able to get up and be vibrant
food is definitely one of the leading
causes if not you know the culprit at
the top at least four to five people
that that we do nutrition and health
counseling with will admit to
experiencing various degrees of brain
fog at various times yeah you're brain
fog meaning that their their their level
of clarity is not very good their memory
is not as good as they know it could be
they have a difficult time concentrating
their their reading comprehension is not
very good all of those those symptoms
that can generally be called brain fog
they can be caused by eating fake food
by putting sugar refined processed
carbohydrates into your body foods with
all kind of chemical additives and
chemical residues from from pesticides
for instance pesticides they kill bugs
because they're their poisons pesticides
are poisons and specifically pesticides
are neurotoxic they actually damage the
the nervous system fact they destroy the
nervous system of an insect that's how
they kill the insect now the government
agency called the FDA which is supposed
to be there to protect the American
public from toxic substances and the
food supply they say that pesticide
residues are fine they kill bugs but
they don't they don't
any harm to people well there's no
science supporting that position but
that's an understandable business policy
in support of the commercial food
industry but pesticides not only are
toxic to insects that can also be toxic
to animals and also human beings and
specifically neurotoxic there's a
nutritionally minded neurologist by the
name of dr. David Perlmutter who's
written a number of books over the years
the better brain book he wrote a very
popular book just a few years ago called
grain brain anyway in his better brain
book from about a dozen years ago he had
a chapter in that book chapter eight
getting the the toxins out and he
identified as a as a neurologist as an
MD neurologist he identified pesticides
as being the most harmful chemicals that
Americans are routinely exposed to that
can ultimately contribute to what we
what I mentioned a few moments ago about
the very common symptom of brain fog
okay your child is mine no I got a nice
gift you think okay your your school
mate wants to share because you know all
right you don't to be stingy but how do
you address the issue so how do you you
know you get one of these kid you guys
like in my old days I love to eat this
I'll beat a box of them what do you guys
have to say what is this this is a
Danish sweet wonderful opportunity for a
mom and dad to begin to educate their
their children about the difference
between real food and fake food kids
sorry I'm impressionable and they like
to look at what their parents are doing
what their older siblings are doing so
first of all the parents setting a good
example for themselves before their
children is is a great start I've worked
with a family with a four-year-old and
she will not eat candy anymore
she's four it's awesome she learned from
her dentist that Candy's bad from her
teeth she learned for me that Candy's
not good for health and you know hearing
it from all these different sources now
she is she's actually more firm than her
parents in not eating candy what about
the common response you usually get well
in moderation okay we we don't eat it
every day maybe a couple times a week
what's the big deal is as a rule
now for the kids you know they're doing
good so we we throw them one of these
are some some lollipops and you know
some other junk food well do you just
want to be a little bit healthier do you
want to be really healthy yeah that's a
very good point and it's also important
to understand that sugar is a highly
addictive substance refined and
processed sugar as I mentioned in our
previous show together
is a it's the most common addictive
stimulant that people use in it in it
and it does have addictive qualities to
it so there's in the in the although
someone may have the intention to only
do a little bit of high sugar fake food
like this
it's perky it's a precarious practice
because many people although their
intention may be to just do a little bit
of it the more they they make that part
of their lifestyle the more prone they
are to actually doing more than a little
bit and they can begin to do it on a
regular basis and more the more and more
they do it the harder and harder it's
going to be for their bottle it's never
just a little it's it's like there's a
piece of candy at the doctor's office
even at the dentist office there's a
piece of candy for the kids and they go
to school and there's cupcakes I mean
it's it doesn't usually it's not usually
just one if it were really just one that
would be different it doesn't stop there
so we're making as sugar addicts from a
young age yeah we continue with that
yeah you know I I know many parents have
the I think incorrect attitude about
about offering their kids very commonly
available sweet sweet treats so that's
you know like ice cream and cookies and
cakes and and all that type of stuff and
they feel like if they don't allow their
children to have some of that that
they're depriving their children I think
a better way to think of it is that your
children need to be protected your
children need to be protected from fake
food and all of the marketing all the
millions and millions of dollars that go
into promoting marketing fake food with
addictive qualities to children
so I don't think a parent is depriving
their child by saying to their child
that this is no this is fake food you
don't this is not something you want to
eat you want to eat real food instead
and educating your children you're not
depriving them you're protecting
children
I like that for something that we say
you want to protect children children
they need to love don't you want to
protect them we right back with more
here in the Dean show don't please
subscribe to the Biggio follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the DS show and we're trying to
save lights can we technically say that
by by educating people in this this area
of something that's it's not too complex
to understand you can actually end up
saving lives we're trying to save love
this is a serious issue what what
Michelle Gillespie and I and all real
nutritionists have to offer people is
how they can save themselves from
unnecessary health problems so you give
them the proper education therefore
proper information now yeah it's up to
them to decide obviously but this is
let's talk about the consequences give
me a few like diabetes obesity this is
like at an epidemic today yeah what
other chronic diseases now you can take
the advice and then this is the positive
outcome or you don't and you continue on
and what are you gonna suffer from well
why do i pressure gimme give me some
more come talk to me well just about
every symptom potentially under the sun
everything from allergies to zits
but if the body is not being nourished
properly it's only a matter of time
before it begins to break down in one
way or another we all have very much in
common but we have our differences we
all have our own unique genetic
strengths and if if you put ten people
together all eating fake food they may
all break down in different ways yeah
for me it was insomnia I had a big
problem with insomnia and improving my
nutrition really helps that and it
doesn't seem like something that would
come from what you eat but there are a
lot of things that you can do with you
to improve your sleep that that's
profound so now you have insomnia you
have diabetes you have heart disease we
mentioned all of these ailments now most
people are also taking some sort of
prescribed drug and that's obviously not
taking care of the problem is it that's
me masking it well right can I be linked
back to food yeah any people don't look
they don't look for the culprit on food
right
the the the father of medicine who to
this day
physicians graduating Medical School
have to take something that called the
Hippocratic oath and the Hippocratic
oath is is named after Hippocrates
Hippocrates was a Greek physician who
practiced several thousand years ago and
his what's that oath again do no harm
well that's part of it but some of the
wisdom that came from Hippocrates was
was this very simple and profoundly
important wisdom let your food be your
medicine and your medicine be your food
that's deep okay but food be your
medicine and medicine be your food right
and most people date this this doesn't
seem to them that is fallible they don't
they don't grasp this I mean I I'm
amazed by it but most people when you
have a a Coke Pepsi potato chips pizza
burger is that your medicine that's
actually prescription to create health
problems that will actually when you go
to a conventional medical doctor then
though they'll put you on so-called
medicine which never addresses the cause
of the problem one last time you've been
to the doctor you go ever you go checkup
every comment I know a year no last time
I I haven't I haven't been to a doctor
because of a health problem since the
70s Oh about yourself I visited an
osteopathic physician not on a regular
basis but I do go hip to him once in a
while for health maintenance yeah for
health maintenance absolutely you this
this seems like this might be getting in
the way I mean you you people like you
if everybody's healthy like this we're
gonna put some people out of business
like well
most important doctor any of us could
ever know is the doctor within ourselves
our body knows how to be healthy it
wants to be healthy the direction of our
life force energy is always toward
towards healing and health if you cut
yourself it heals you know if you get
injured in a in a martial arts workout
or you you injure yourself any other way
through any activity that you're engaged
and your body has a capacity to heal
itself the healing doesn't happen
magically the body needs to be supported
well enough in order for us to realize
our full healing potential but the most
important doctor any of us could have
respect for into honor is the doctor
within ourselves I need to the person
says I look they know they need to lose
a hundred pounds where do they start how
did they start they're addicted to
somebody's food there's habits now that
they accustomed to to wake up in the
morning with was the frosted flakes and
you know stack full of pancakes then a
good place to start would be breakfast
right for the start right there you can
start with anything that feels right to
you breakfast is the first meal of the
day it makes sense to start with that
takeout junk food and and add in real
food I think that's the first step you
don't have to have a perfect diet from
day one just pick one thing that you're
that you're passionate about that you
can that you feel you can make a change
with and make a change there on baby
steps okay so take one thing out that's
bad can we start with start with the
white process refined sugar
isn't it true also that now the
marketing it's really interesting I
heard this from my strengthen condition
ago he said that that sugar they also
they keep changing the name they given
it so many different like cover-ups
names so you can't identify it
evaporated cane juice and give it give
us so many days what high fructose corn
syrup corn syrup all their different
kinds of sugar beet sugar so these
things if you see it this is what you
want to stay away from this is a good
start well
remember I said and
my first appearance on the Dean show
Eddie that the simplest teaching I have
to offer about nutrition call this
nutrition 101 is that if you want to be
real healthy then eat real food and real
food is simple food that does not come
with a label with a list of ingredients
so if you're reading foods if you're if
you're buying foods that that come with
a label with a list of ingredients yeah
it is important to read those
ingredients and sugar can be disguised
in a lot of different ways but a higher
level of nutritional consciousness and
practice to actually realize is where
you're you're not reading
you're not buying foods that have labels
with lists list of ingredients generally
speaking you know there can be some
exceptions to that but the best quality
real foods that God nature have to offer
us you know fresh ideally pesticide free
organic vegetables and fruits and whole
raw non salted non roasted nuts and
seeds and legumes which are beans
lentils and peas and whole organic grain
products and then meats and fish seafood
[Applause]